ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد العلاقات
الفرنسيه الالمانيه تشهد خلافات متصاعده
وخاصه في مسائل الطاقه والدفاع وذلك عقب
انزلاع الحرب الروسيه لاوكرانيه بشان ملف
الغزل والسيطر المانيا ان رئيس الفرنسي
مقروء حاول اجبار المستشار الالماني
ولافشورس على تحديد سقف اسعار الغاز الامر
الذي وصفته صحف المانيه بانه محاوله
لارضاء خبلين من خلال تصريحات قاسيه
والحناء لم يتوقف من جهه النظر او من وجهه
النظر الفرنسيه يعتبر رئيس مكروه ان
المانيا امام مسؤوليه تاريخيه لكنها بدلا
من ان تقف امام مسؤوليتها تحاول التغريده
خارج سرب الاتحاد الاوروبي في مسائل
الدفاع والطاقه لدرجه ان البعض يصف شورز
بانه اقل تقديرا للعلاقات الفرنسيه
الالمانيه من المستشاره السابقه انجلار
امريكا
وقائع كثيره او وقائع كثيره منها جمود
مشاريع دفاع المشتركه فالمانيا تقوده
مبادره من دون فرنسا لاقامه درعا جوي
بمشاركه 14 دوله من دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
الاعضاء في حرش شمال الاطلسي على اساس
معدات امريكيه واسرائيليه وهذا امر وجدت
فيه باريس خرقا في مبدا السياده
والاستقلال
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا باريس
المخلل السياسي اسامه حريري اهلا بك وين
مدينه بون الالمانيه رئيس المركز الاوروبي
لدراسه السياسيه والامنيه جاسم محمد اهلا
بكم ضيوف الكرام واسمحولي ان ابدا من
المانيا معك يا استاذ جاسم استاذ جاسم هذه
الانتقادات المتبادله في ملفات طاقه
والمناكفات في ملف الدفاع هل هي مؤشر
حقيقي سيشق وحده اوروبا تعتقد
بدون شك هنالك يتصدع كبير في المحور
الفرنسي الالماني وعندما نتحدث عن الفرنسي
المحور الفرنسي الالماني نحن نتحدث عن
قاطره الاتحاد الاوروبي وهذا يعني بين
الانشقاقات عندما تصل الى هذا الحد ما بين
باريس و برلين هذا يعني بان هنالك التصدع
كبير يهدد بتمارسك هذا الاتحاد وكذلك ايضا
تعصب في هذا الاتحاد الذي اصبح عشه خاصه
ما بعد مغادرته بريطانيا من هذا الاتحاد
الخلافات الفرنسيه الالمانيه يبدو انه كان
لم تظهر الى العلن برغم انها كانت موجوده
لكن اجد انه سياسه الشرطه الالماني جديد
اصبحت ليس موضوع الترحيب من قبل ماكرون
وربما هذه يعني لو تحدثنا في سياسات الامن
وكذلك في سياسه الطاقه نلاحظ انه المانيا
يعني تنهض في الانفاق العسكري وهنالك هي
اكثر من 100 مليار حددتها المانيا لين
تكون فيها الانفاق العسكري وكذلك في
موضوعات طاقه مثل ما جاء في التقرير هنا
لكميتين مليار حددتها المانيا في سبيل
الدعم الشركات وكذلك المشتركين في مجال
الطاقه هذا يعتبر بان مزدوجا همم سياسه او
خطوه انانيه من قبل البانيا
وهذا ربما هو سبب انتقادات همم فرنسا
المانيا لماذا تعزل نفسها او تذهب الى اعز
الناس عن الاتحاد الاوروبي همم سيد اسامه
من يتحمل مسؤوليه تدهور العلاقه بين فرنسا
والمانيا نعلم بان التفاصيل همم كثيره همم
وتعود حتى الاتفاقيه الدفاع لسنه 2017
ولكن من الذي اخلى
بامكانيه ان تكون هناك اتفاقيات لانه اول
مره نتابع تصريحات بهذا الوضوح وبهذا
الصراحه من رئيس الفرنسيه تهم فيها الجهه
الالمانيه
من يتحمل المسؤوليه يعني اولا يمكن القول
ان الظروف التي اجبرت كل من المانيا
وفرنسا ان تجد انفسهما في هذه يعني في هذه
المرحله من العلاقات المتوتره هي المسؤول
الاساسي يعني الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
روسيا
لاوكرانيا انا شخصيا اعتقد ان يعني هناك
كانت انتقادات كثيره من قبل الصحافه
الفرنسيه حتى وساسه الفرنسيه لالمانيا
بانها تغرد تغرد خارج السرب وبانها يعني
تحاول الخروج قليلا من تحت عباءه الاتحاد
الاوروبي واعتقد ان هذه الانتقادات يعني
في مكانها من ناحيه انها يعني وما اخذ
فرنسا على المانيا ان المانيا اصبحت يعني
راينا تحركاته تحرك الى في شرطه قام به
الى الصين اخضر كثيرا فرنسا وكانه المانيا
تريد ان همم تؤمن مصالحها اولا وهذا من
حقها طبعا ولكن على حساب الاتحاد الاوروبي
ووحده الاتحاد الاوروبي مثلا الاتفاق
الكبير الذي همم عقده مع الرئيس الصيني
لبيع الصين جزء من مرفا هامبورغ اغضب
باريس كثيرا باضافه الى الجولات التي قام
بها الاوف شولت الى السعوديه وقطر
والامارات لتامين امدادات طاقه اكثر الى
المانيا عدا عن ذلك هناك مسائل الدفاع
ولقد تكلمت عنها بشكل موجز في تقرير مساكن
مساء الدفاع ايضا مساء تعقد جدا العلاقه
بين فرنسا والمانيا لان المانيا اصبحت
يعني تصرف اكثر على ميزانتها الدفاعيه
تقريبا 100 مليار يورو بالجيس وهذه
الميزانيه المانيا ستبدا بشراء طائرات
امريكيه من نوع 35 بدل ان تشتري من فرنسا
حريفها الاول في اوروبا اضف على ذلك طبعا
مساله ال همم
استاذ اسامه في هذه الجزئيه المانيا كذلك
لها المانيا تقول باننا اول على الفرنسي
ولكن المناكفات بين الشريكتين
اخره توفير المعدات التي طلبناها وبالتالي
كذلك فرنسا فهمت ااا المانيا تهمت فرنسا
بالمماطله
بخصوص يعني الطائره الهجوميه وهو الخلاف
بين يعني بخصوص شركتي داسو واغبيس نعم
صحيح ولكن يعني في نفس الوقت في مرحله
المعاينه يجب ان يتم ان كل طرف ان يقدم
تنازل على فنسى ان تقدم تنازلته على
المانيا ان تقدم التنازلات لكي يتم
الاتفاق الى يعني ايجاد حل وسط يعني نوعا
ما بين البلدين لانه في حال قامت فعلا
المانيا بالابتعاد عن هذا الثنائي الذي
يعرف بالثنائي الفرنسي الالماني ستصبح
اوروبا اضعف وسيكون يعني ربما البوتين حقق
هدفه في القيامه يعني
الاتحاد الاوروبيه
لاسبانيا فما المتاح ما الحل وسط هذا ما
تقوله المانيا على كل حضرتك تتكلم عن انا
المانيا تخرج السر تحدث بنفس المنطقه
خارج السرب همم على حساب الاتحاد الاوروبي
بل هو اكثر تضرب بعرض حائط كلام وتصريحات
اا حلفاء الاوروبيين
لا بالعكس انه المانيا هي قاطره الاتحاد
الاوروبيه وهي من انقذت همم يعني العديد
من الدول والمقاصه الجنوب اوروبا اليونان
اسبانيا وايطاليا وغيرها من الكوارث
الاقتصاديه اجد انه من اكثر الدول الداعمه
الى هذا الاتحاد وتتبناه ك- حتى على مستوى
ثقافه شعبيه في المانيا انه هي داعمه الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي ولذلك نرى انه شورت هو
يدعم ايضا الى توي هذا الاتحاد الاوروبي
ليش يشمل الشارقه اوروبا دول جديده وربما
تكون هنالك دائره جديده من الدول الشركه
الى الاتحاد الاوروبي ما تحمله
لحد الان اجد انه يثير الغضب همم او ربما
هواجس امنيه من قبل فرنسا المانيا تريد ان
تلعب دور جديد في مسؤول الدفاع هي وجدت
بان قرارها سياسي وخاصه في النزاعات
الدوليه يحتاج الى رافعه واصبح مفهومه في
الجيب والتكن لا يوجد قرار سياسي بدون ان
يكون هنالك يعني قوه عسكريه وامنيه تدعم
هذا القرار ولل ولذلك نلاحظ انه مخرجات
مؤتمر برلين وكذلك مؤتمر برلين واحد
واثنين حول ليبيا لم ينجح بسبب وجود ثغره
في موضوع رافعه سياسيه الى القرار
الالماني فاذا هنالك هاجس امني اذا سمحتي
لي عند الفرنسيين بسبب تراكمات التاريخيه
عهد ناسيه التي عاشتها المانيا عام 1943
هذه جميع ربما تثير الكثير من الشكوك في
قدرات المانيا الجديده خاصه ان الدستور
الالماني الان يسمح ربما في ان يكون للجيش
الالماني دورا جديدا في لا يتحدث فيها
الدعم اللوجستي بقدر ما يكون هنالك دعم
يعني دور قتال وهذا الكلام يا استاذ جاسم
ياخذنا لاطار اخر يعني لم نعد نتحدث عن
مشاكل في ايجاد حلول متبادله ولكن حتى
حضرتك تتحدث عن عدم ثقه بين طرفين ما رايك
سيد اسامه ضيف يقول بان اا فرنسا لا تتكلم
دفاعا عن الوحده الاوروبيه هي تتكلم لان
لديها مخاوف من المانيا وبالعوده لتاريخها
خاصه
صحيح يعني الجزئيا اوافق سيد جاسم الموضوع
ان فرنسا لديها مخاوفها ربما ليست
بالضروره تتعلق بالتاريخ القديمه عن تاريخ
الحرب العالميه الثانيه ولكن لديها مخاوف
فعليه فرنسا اعتقد ان المانيا لمده طويله
من بعد سقوط جدار برلين يعني لعبت دوري
يعني نوعا ما القوه التي تكون في الظل
تكون في الخلفيه كنا دائما نتحدث عن ان
فرنسا هي القوه الدبلوماسيه الاولى في
اوروبا وان المانيا هي قوه اقتصاديه
الاولى ويعني فرنسا والمانيا تقدان اوروبا
الى الامام اليوم يعني ربما تشعر تشعر
قليلا بانها تحررت نوعا ما من هذه تحررت
يعني من ربما من السيطره الفرنسيه وبيكون
فرنسا كانت دائما في الواجهه وهي اليوم
ايضا اصبحت تريد ايضا ان تكون في الواجهه
ان يكون لها دور سياسي دوبلوماسي فاعل ان
يكون لها حتى دور عسكري فاعل ان يكون
لديها جيشها القوي ولهذا السبب استثمرت
تقريبا 100 مليار يورو لدعم الجيش عن هذه
النقطه هو يقول لك بان هناك متغيرات جيو
سياسيه تسمعني سيد اسامه ضيف يقول لك هناك
متغيرات جيوس سياسيه والمانيا تدرك بان
لتحقيق هذه المتغيرات يجب كذلك عليها ان
تكون قوه عسكريه هل اخطات المانيا في هذا
التقديرات بحسب رايك
اذا اخطات انا اعتقد ستكون المانيا اخطات
فعلا اذا اصبح الخلاف كبير جدا بين فرنسا
واذا كلا طرفين لا اريد ان اتخذ الطرف
الفرنسي بالضروره ان اكون الى طرف الى
جانب فرنسا ولكن في حال كده الطرفان لم
يتوصل الى حال وسط نعم ستكون فرنسا قد
اخطات والمانيا ايضا قد اخطاء جدا لان
بالنهايه مصلحه كل من فرنسا والمانيا هي
في اتحاد اوروبي قوي همم
لانه اكيد هناك من يدافع كذلك عن وجهه نظر
هذا استاذ جاسم بكل هذه الخلافات وبنعدام
الثقه ان فهمته منكم ما بين طرفين المانيا
وفرنسا او على الاقل حتى اكون دقيقه ولكن
بتراجع الثقه بين الطرفين كيف لهذه الوحده
همم ان تتابع طريقه بسلام الوحده
الاوروبيه تحدث
لو تحدثنا اولا عن التقارب او المقاربه
الفرنسيه الالمانيه يجد الان هما في
الطريقين مختلفين يعني اجد انه اتجاه
فرنسا بدا يتجه نحو الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا اكثر مما يتجه في نحو المانيا
لكن لو تحدثنا عن توجه الاتحاد الاوروبي
الاتحاد الاوروبي هو اصلا يعيش الكثير من
الانقسامات هنالك انقسام ما بين الشرق
والغرب ونتذكر اعتقد زميل او ضيف الكريم
من باريس يتذكر الموضوع كتلته في شرق
اوروبا التي تدعمها هنغاريا كيف كانت
تراهن على ان يكون هنالك موقف ربما ضد
الكتله الغربيه في موضوع خاصه الهجره
ومسائل اخرى انه هيك بان الاتحاد الاوروبي
ايضا القرارات المصيريه يتخذها هو
بالاجماع وهذا يعني انه الحصول على هذا
الاجماع يعد صعب ولذلك ادركت بعض اربع
وهنالك يا اصوات ربما من الداخل ومن داخل
المانيا يجب ان يغير النظام الداخلي الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي فاذا للاتحاد الاوروبي
يتجه نحو ال ال التفكك اكثر اما المحور
الفرنسي فيجد للاسف انه لا تكون هنالك
مقاربه ايجابيه لحد هذه اللحظه سؤال
باختصار والاجابه مختصره انت كرامت سيد
اسامه هل نحن بصدد همم
امكانيه ان تتوتر العلاقات وان يصبح
الاتحاد الاوروبي من الماضي ام هناك
مبالغه في القول ذلك
الاتحاد الاوروبي من الماضي على مدى قصير
ربما متوسطه الى ماذا اعتقد هناك نوع من
المبالغه لان يجب الا نمس يعني دائما كانت
فرنسا والمانيا خلال السنوات الماضيه يعني
اجتاحت اوروبا مشاكل عديده كبيره جدا مثل
ازمه الهجره مثل مساله خروج المملكه
المتحده البريطانيه من الاتحاد الاوروبي
وفي كل مره كانت فرنسا والمانيا عبر
الحوار تتوصلان يعني الى نوع من الاتفاق
بالتالي هنا السؤال هل سيكون هناك يعني
طبعا اليوم همم المانيا يقودها الى شولت
ولا ينقضها انجلا ماركل وهذا استيدا تفصيل
مهم جدا يجب ان لا ننسى بالتالي السؤال
سيبقى يعني هل سيتمكن اولاف شولد
وماكرون من تجاوز هذه الخلافات كما فعلت
صادقا مع النظاره
كذلك سيقول لك بان فرنسا اليوم
يقودها جاك شيراك
الاسماء كذلك قد تؤثر هذه العلاقات
او شكرا لكم جزيل الشكر من همم باريس
اسامه حريري المحلل السياسي وشكر كذلك لك
من مدينه بول الالمانيه رئيس المركز
الاوروبيه الى الدراسات السياسيه والامنيه
جاء السماء محمد شكرا لكم